do you have a [ __ ] question for us I
do yeah go ahead I'm hopeful advice go
do the thing don't do it no you're right
yeah unhelpful advice barbeque very go
ila in George hello gang
I have an issue with communication I am
married and I have a hard time just
talking with my husband
I love how Bobby and kalila talk about
everything with confidence and it could
be about anything when I listen to you
on Soundcloud I feel better like I have
something to talk about with my husband
how can i improve my communication
skills and become more confident in many
random conversations thank you for your
time Michele you notice we all we should
just answer like three questions since
four questions tonight since we don't
have the energy to talk about other
things let's just be as unhelpful as we
can to other people I don't even listen
to that
say it again I have an issue with
communication I'm married and I have a
hard time talking with my husband I love
how Bobby and kalila talk about
everything with confidence and it could
be about it you know listen Clara and I
we took a podcast we talk it's fluid
because well you're forced to talk
really but I think : I have a good but
I'm comfortable with her like if I'm in
a car if we fight like we did last night
you know it's like shocking I get angry
I get really angry but at the end of the
day I just kind of know that you know
this is what a relationship is and a
relationship sometimes you know you're
gonna you're gonna argue but um but we
don't it's not like we talk but we do
are you crazy yeah we do talk a lot yeah
I I just slide we have to talk so much
well she wants to know how can she
improve her communication skills be more
confident in random conversation I I
don't know because I think that some
relationships work well and they're
quiet and they don't have to be as a
vocal as Bobby and art and I are towards
each other but if it's something that
you feel is amiss or lacking in your
relationship then you should just say
like you know initiate conversation see
if we what if he takes the bait and if
he wants to go back and forth with you
on certain topics but if he's somebody
who just likes
isn't quiet then you're [ __ ] you know
I mean I've been in relationships before
where I'd bring up a topic or something
that I just wanted to talk about and the
other person just couldn't volley with
me not you know and sometimes it just
wasn't they didn't either either they
didn't want to or they couldn't and um
you know that those relationships ended
and I'm I got super lucky with Bobby
because we just volley back and forth
like idiots and I don't know it just
happened organically for us it wasn't
something that we tried to do or that we
didn't try to communicate better we just
did
[Music]